This ellipse would be centered at 2, negative 1. Good thinking if you found
this point. This would be the basic ellipse centered at the origin. So, first
we want to subtract 2 from x. And remember, subtracting 2 moves the ellipse to
the right 2 units. Now, we just want to add 1 to y. And when we add 1 to y, our
ellipse really shifts down one unit. So, again, here was our original ellipse,
centered at the origin. That would be this equation. And then, we shifted it
two units to the right, since we subtracted 2, and then we shifted it one unit
down, since we added 1 to y. Remember that these numbers are the opposite in
the direction. So, you might think negative 2 would shift our ellipse two units
to the left. But in fact it shifts our ellipse two units to right. Likewise
with y, we might think our ellipse would move up one unit, but it turns out our
ellipse moves down one unit. This is the same idea that we saw for circles, and
it goes against our intuition. You want to be careful about it.